[Music]
Sam borrowed money from a shell company
which borrowed money from Alameda which
borrowed money from blockfi and it was
with that money with which he bought his
seven percent stake in Robin Hood it's
[ __ ] crazy that is wild I did not
know that even thinking about the effect
of altruism you know going to crypto
Bahamas and seeing where they lived
right this is very antithetical to the
sort of I drive a Corolla Mantra that
that was put out there when you think of
this whole situation what's the like
single most surprising part
all right guys bang bang I've got Frank
here the uh third best podcaster in all
of the Bitcoin crypto world I'm the
first Peter McCormick is second you're a
third fair I think that that's debatable
but it's your show so I can't argue with
you when I come on yours you say you're
first I'll say I'm first and you'll know
you'll be second I'll actually give you
a spot above Peter yeah that's perfect
all right uh there's all kinds of stuff
going on I figured you'd be the perfect
person to talk about the events that
have transpired but then also we can
kind of go back and forth ask some
questions whatever uh first what's your
read on the whole STX situation like how
did this happen how did this happen
um I mean that tell us everything that's
a loaded question well well where where
can we start we can start with the fact
that
um clearly there were a lot of things
that were going on behind the scenes
that gave us sort of
there were like little morsels of
evidence if we can use that word okay
um going to the fact that there were
these two firms that were very
intertwined and we all kind of knew that
that was a little strange but we never
kind of pulled the thread I think a lot
of people ask questions about it so that
was one factor it turns out that they
were very intertwined not only
intertwined but FDX or rather Alameda
was able to leverage the customer
deposits on FTX to some in some shape or
form it could have been a back door that
Sam created he claims he did not he
claims he can't even code it could have
been uh just the fact that Alameda was
just borrowing from FTX based on the
deposits there so clearly that
relationship which a lot of people
thought was suspect was in fact but even
just I think like what I've been
thinking about the last few weeks
is just how bizarre it was for a firm to
kind of grow in the way it did and have
the presence that it did right 130
million dollar
um Arena deal with Miami Heat
um you know million dollar properties in
the Bahamas I mean they literally
Sam literally had restaurants there stay
open 24 7 and serve just vegan food for
him
he racked up a 55 000 bill at the uh
Margaritaville so a lot of these things
it's actual it's in the bankruptcy
filings a lot of these things in
hindsight it's like actually yeah that
stuff was weird and we were talking
about this before uh we turned on the
mic I asked a lot of these questions
um
poked at especially
the relationship between these two firms
but in hindsight I think we we didn't
fully get to it and it wasn't until we
had that that Silver Bullet as it were
the balance sheet that brought the
entire house of cards to its knees and
it's funny to to sort of see
um or it's not funny it's unfortunate
but it is it's it's interesting that
um
for me at least in hindsight it it makes
sense that
it was all kind of just yeah a bunch of
for gazy so I have a couple of questions
one is uh
assuming that what happened was Alameda
had access to customer deposits which I
again it's alleged but like I think a
lot of people believe that uh is the
case
um
thank you
if they'd never touched the customer
funds
would the business have been as big like
could it have been true in terms of how
profitable they were how much Capital
they raised like all these things and it
was actually like this one thing that
they did brought it all down but it
would have been one of the great stories
of Entrepreneurship and and kind of
business creation if they never actually
crossed
fun customer deposits yeah and this is
the Rubicon which you should never cross
right yeah in capital markets this is
the biggest No-No it will they also
appear to have told again I went back
and I read some of the uh user uh kind
of terms of service like they say they
don't touch the funds they said they
don't touch the funds and the terms of
service they said it to me in interviews
they set it to Regulators in
conversations Sam told me he told
Regulators that there are these strict
walls between the two firms so yes they
were that was
erroneous but to get to the heart of
your question which I think is deeply
fascinating is
the
what could have happened here and
there's two possible scenarios right the
first of which is it was a strong
business Alameda was printing money
doing very well as a trading firm and
then things slipped up around Terra Luna
and
they had to think fast act fast and they
made a decision to maybe borrow too much
from their sister company or
the worst case scenario scenario
actually tap into those funds to win it
all back as it were
that's sort of like
that's one possible situation the other
situation is and this is where and I
talked to him about this on my show at
the beginning of or rather at the end of
last year the 2019 story
um and it seemed very conspiratorial at
the time because it was so outlandish
what is the story the story was that
Alameda was a trading firm that made a
really
um outsized bet and did well on the
kimchi trade of sort of arving between
the Western exchanges and the and the
ones in Korea
um South Korea because there was this
huge premium because of capital
restrictions
um Capital outflow restrictions in that
country and so they made it big and then
there was there were trades that went
bust and Alameda was like in a really
bad position and so they effectively
launched FTX as a way to fill a hole
that Alameda had so going back to what I
was saying before it either was
something that the the sort of turn of
events happened either very you know
recently within the past six months
stemming from that original capital or
credit crisis that the crypto Market saw
or this is a much longer story a much
more Insidious story that stems back to
the origin of of FDX and Alameda what do
you think it is well here's the thing
like we don't necessarily have and I
don't have the the facts per se or
evidence there are sources I've talked
to within Alameda who who said that this
back door or at least this relationship
between the firms have existed since the
beginning
hard in this market right to kind of
discern what people's motives are what
their intentions are and whether or not
they're speaking badly about someone
because of their own book as as it were
so it's difficult to say
we're going to find out a lot of
interesting things in the coming days
and weeks and months and it's going to
be and then years afterwards so
it's it's difficult to say
um but if I were to
if I were to have a gun held to my head
no guns here but God good I'm safe my
head is safe I I would I think that it's
been just completely mismanaged from the
beginning I think that um you know
there's a possibility of fraud at least
with respect to a misrepresentation to
regulators
let's put attentions aside they don't
really matter right they don't really
intentions don't really matter people
were hurt and lied to and so that's
where you can possibly run into some
issues
and he'd I mean there was
misrepresentations I mean even going
back to the 2019 story that we first
reported on ftx's launch Sam said to us
that they would if he would imminently
step down as CEO of Alameda he didn't do
that until the end of 2021
so there was nothing imminent about that
he also said that they were doing in
2021 there were Gap audits that showed
the the financial uh stability of the
business
John Ray the current CEO paints a very
wildly different story of a lack of
financial controls a lack of basically
everything you would expect from a
business that's acting quasi as a shadow
Bank there was nothing I mean they were
approving you know expenses via VIA
slack emojis
and you know what is you know
if any other company was doing that it
would just be egregious like we would
have maybe
picked up on it a bit more but
what they did so masterfully was really
throw a bunch of glitter into our eyes
if you think about it right with with
the sponsorship deals with
um
just the
genesequa that was his bizarre
um do they ever say aesthetic do they
ever send you guys uh balance sheets or
anything as like reporters
we never we never got any sort of
balance sheet from that so no balance
sheets but also then like what about
like Gap financials or audits or
anything like that so they told us that
they had they had those and at the end
of 2021 they said they were gonna be
releasing the Gap financials for 20 22 I
think or rather in 2022 they were going
to release 2021
they never did they I don't know here's
the other thing that I've been
reflecting on I don't know if
we never we never got them but I also
think so much was happening post covid
and I I spoke to Vanity Fair about this
the Go-Go era
of crypto without the proper like
controls and like self regulation or
outside regulation from from Regulators
I think allowed the market to kind of
get out of control and you know when you
have and now and and maybe this is part
of their strategy
they were announcing things every week
so as a reporter let's say you were on
the FTX beat
it's very hard to sort of sit back and
think okay
what what is weird here like we'd ask
the questions but to go deeper because
they were constantly putting out
information where we're opening up an
office in Chicago we'd have the Miami
Heat deal we're moving to Bahamas now
we're working with the Bahamian
government on dare and they inundated
the market with all this information
and in hindsight it's reasonable to
think that there was a strategic element
there to to distract while they fixed or
or or did something else
um but these are some of the things I've
been I've been reflecting on and
they're they're a lot of a lot of
strange
um strange stuff right like even
thinking about the effect of altruism
that is probably the one thing I I would
kick myself about is
you know going to crypto Bahamas and
seeing the you know where they lived
right did you go to the apartment
not his apartment but I I sort of you
know did a tour Day Day NASA as it were
and
I mean this is this is luxury this isn't
you know they weren't living like
talmudic monks right like this is
this is very antithetical to the sort of
I drive a Corolla uh Mantra that that
was put out there and I I wish that I
kind of picked up on that a little bit
more and what I thought at the time was
almost
okay like you know people make a lot of
money in crypto
let's say they're all living together
it makes sense that they would go all in
or sort of split the the costs right and
you know if it's a 10 million dollar
house and 10 million 10 people live in
it it's a million dollar house I
wouldn't
a million dollar house doesn't raise
eyebrows especially in this um market
right so that's kind of how I thought
about it but in hindsight definitely
definitely is a bit peculiar given the
sort of effective altruism and and
humility that underpinned a lot of the
marketing do you think he's gonna get in
trouble or do you think that uh it'll be
like a whoops made a mistake
uh and well he's definitely painting the
the story as a whoops I made a mistake
that's the toughest question right I
mean because there's a very fine line
between
um mismanagement being
um
um incapable of properly running a
company
and fraud right
um I believe that you know even in 2008
there was a lot of bad management no one
went to jail right except for that one
guy who like uh you know
misappropriated uh Goldman Sachs is
proprietary trading uh algorithms data
or whatever it was
and then you have Elizabeth Holmes who
is going to jail for 11 years so
I think on both sides you you or rather
in both instances you would say people
did things bad
but it doesn't necessarily translate
into that sort of corporal punishment
necessarily does he get in trouble
generally like in a very like deep sense
yeah I think he's in he's in pretty big
trouble yeah well he's in trouble but I
mean like uh I guess in the most extreme
jail time right uh barred from the
financial industry like you can kind of
go down the line there's a bunch of
punishments that historically have been
loving I mean John Corzine didn't spend
a day in jail for MF Global and they're
similar
um
again whereas Elizabeth Holmes right
like basically lied to her investors and
she's spending quite a bit of time in
jail yeah and liked Regulators I believe
yeah
um what about the relationship between
the Bahamas and the United States
because I would have thought
um pre this event
the United States and the Bahamas are
friendly
if something happens that involves a U.S
citizen or U.S customers whatever the
Bahamas basically would say hey you guys
are the United States like do your thing
but I saw a letter that was sent from
like the Bohemian security Regulators
they were like this is a Bohemian
incident uh you don't have jurisdiction
here basically is what they were saying
and that surprised me is that should I
have been surprised maybe do I am not
educated and didn't understand that
that's the position they would take or
what did you think about that this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
in each sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep I wasn't surprised
because the way that these
bankruptcy proceedings work
oftentimes you have disputes between
jurisdictions especially ones that are
playing a shell game right so I wouldn't
be surprised if you see other
jurisdictions try to sort of step up to
the plate and carve out their part of
the pie with the Bahamas in particular
if I were to speculate
this is deeply personal right it's uh
well what I mean by that is it's it it
hits home for them in a unique way right
it's a country of 400 000 people
and they really went in there and and
usurped a lot of like
energy right
um there was the conference that they
had they I mean this is this is a rumor
I'm gonna share it because it's funny I
don't know if this is true and I hope I
hope you know folks forgive me for for
caveating a rumor I am but it's a funny
rumor it's not it's not illicit or
anything so I'm gonna share it there's a
story apparently early on when they
first moved down there
um Sam uh got all the employees to the
Bahamas and uh so there's a hundred of
them and they rang up one of the local
burrito places and asked for a hundred
burritos by lunchtime and the restaurant
was of you know they weren't they
weren't annoyed they were just confused
and said we literally do not have the
manpower to make that many burritos or
or not even the Manpower but the sort of
like the ingredients the ingredients and
like the the the the infrastructure
Capital infrastructure infrastructure to
do it so he bought them like three more
ovens or something so that they could
like or stoves so that they could
produce as many burritos as needed for
the FTX staff and apparently there's
another restaurant where they uh he
basically paid them to stay open 24 7
and
offer vegan Alternatives so they really
went in there and kind of like changed a
bit of the fabric of the society and and
in the aftermath of this I think these
regulators and these government
officials like they know how deeply
impacted their constituents are in a way
that
sure millions of Americans were impacted
but
I think there was a stat that like it
was projected or um
expected that FTX contributed to 10 of
the Bahamian GDP wow so that's I mean I
I'm not surprised that they're trying to
you know puff their chest right to at
least show or at least exert their
authority over something that so deeply
was interwoven with the fabric of their
small
um with a smaller island nation I went
to the Bahamas once for an interview do
you know this no with who uh not with
Sam uh SPF and FTX we're not there uh I
went and I interviewed John McAfee on
his boat really oh yeah is that that
infamous picture of you and his and his
wife me John and his wife with uh they
have guns and I do not so you know
what's funny is I actually downloaded I
got Snapchat again huh and I had John's
number from 2017. okay I called him a
few times
you know God Rest us all and the coin of
the day that's what he was doing back
then that's what that was the good old
days but I opened Snapchat and it's like
John McAfee Snapchat because it kind of
loads your contacts
but I guess his number has gone to some
kid who's like you know who's like
uploading stuff like this kid you know
he doesn't know
uh yeah but I do remember like uh I have
a picture
uh what you made me think of is uh so I
went uh one of my brothers came with me
and uh he told us where they were and we
got there and like you know I'm no fool
I uh gonna make sure that everything is
uh on the up and up before I go walking
onto some dude's boat who I know has a
bunch of guns so we kind of got there a
little early and I went and I sat and
there was like a bar uh that kind of
overlooking the like Harbor or whatever
um and uh and as I was sitting there I
saw a big ass wood sign
and had the name of the place on it and
I walked down and across the top they
put a second sign they got like a nicely
made sign to the same quality as the
original sign and it said home of John
McAfee
I remember thinking like how much
business has he brought to this little
bar and of course right now wasn't 10 of
the GP or anything like that but like
that was one man exactly this is a whole
company I was worth you know supposedly
32 billion dollars that basically did
the exact same thing on a way bigger
scale and six months ago or however many
months ago were breaking ground on a um
thousand person office so they actually
break ground like were they building it
they you know the yeah yeah you know
where they kind of throw the dirt over
but they were but they were in the
motion the ceremony is there a word for
that I don't know like breaking ground
breaking ground cutting the ribbon I
think yeah
but no they hadn't laid that
foundational the Cornerstone right
um when you think of this whole
situation what's the like single most
surprising part is it just that like it
happened or is there something where
you're like I cannot believe this detail
foreign
it's all of the details right I mean
you know what's so funny is
when I think back about like FTX Alameda
the most egregious
impropriety that I thought could be
um the case would have been that maybe
Alameda like could see the order book
faster could access ftx's Market faster
you know going back to like the the IEX
sort of like story of you know uh Flash
Boys where maybe FTX or rather Alameda
had more
um more visibility into the market that
was FTX relative to other Traders
I couldn't possibly have imagined that
Sam
would have been so levered to the tits
I'll tell you actually the most
surprising and upsetting I think fact is
is that
he
borrowed money
uh or took rather block fight customer
funds
and that was borrowed by Alameda which
then block fire I mean I don't think
they would know I mean they borrowed a
talamita thinking that Alameda would use
it for trading strategies Alameda then
lent that out to an entity owned by Sam
which then bought his steak in Robin
Hood
I mean
I just couldn't imagine run that back
again sorry yeah so Sam I guess a more
clear way to put it borrowed money from
a shell company
which borrowed money from Alameda which
borrowed money from blockfi
300 something million dollars and it was
with that money
that leveraged levered levered money
with which he bought his seven percent
stake in Robin Hood
it's it's it's it's it's
[ __ ] crazy that is wild I did not
know that yeah that went out like a few
days ago
um you're you're that's your job to know
that stuff I mean I just I said look let
me just come here you're a wealth of
knowledge yeah I just you know all right
so what are you gonna do different
because I think that you've like thought
a lot about uh how many times did you
interview them six times on the show but
I mean but talk to him or other people
at the company many times throughout the
years yeah yeah you know it was it was
really good at and and
he was very good at like speaking about
a wide range of topics so
it kind of was almost like FTX a certain
point became boring it was like all
right they're growing their market share
whatever but there's all this stuff
happening in the market Luna is melting
down there seems to be these credit
issues and so he was good about Solana
was growing all these different
ecosystems were growing and so a lot of
the conversations were about those
topics like what do you think about
what's your strategy for serum what's
your opinion on sort of um even what the
fed's doing right and he was so willing
to opine on many of these on these
topics that it almost sort of distracted
from
um
um
the core business so when I think about
what I might like what I think is
important for all of us to do for all of
us to do is to you know without being
abrasive like ask really tough questions
I think I think you really
um
your interview at CNBC like they were
really tough and I think you like
handled those tough questions well but
they weren't done in a uh malicious way
where it was like I'm gonna yell and
scream I'm gonna yeah exactly dunk on
you or try to embarrass you but they
were like I think I said like they're
fair questions yeah there's no animus
and
so with the podcast like except for it
was 20 minutes it was long that was a
long day I don't think I went I needed
like an IV after that like 20 minutes on
national television and like the heat's
on start sweating yeah that's tough uh I
think just in general like I always I've
always viewed my jobs over the past you
know I've been doing this for not that
long seven years
um as kind of being a conduit for
investors and clients of of these
companies that I cover
and ask the questions that they would
ask if they had the opportunity to sit
across from somebody
um I'm gonna I think we need I need to
be a little bit meaner a little bit more
yeah uh it's it's a good question right
because
people accuse me all the time of uh
softball interviews all this stuff yeah
and uh one one of them
um I had uh
uh
see a good example I had Chris Larson um
on the uh podcast and I don't think him
nor I were confused that like we didn't
see eye to eye on some things but it was
like a I want to ask you these questions
so that I can get the answers other
people get the answers and then like
people decide what they want to decide
but like answer the questions to his
credit he said yeah sure let's do it
so you got on I don't think I asked easy
questions like I was like hey you
realize that there's no one person in
the world who could change the code of
Bitcoin right he was like well yeah
which contradicted what had publicly
been said in the change the code
um uh kind of initiative but there's
other things that he explained when kind
of elaborated on that people had read
that maybe his view uh wasn't nearly as
egregious as they had previously thought
or whatever and so I've always
approached it as just like it's
important to have conversations with the
people you agree with and the people you
disagree with and by the way it's not
like I walked out of that conversation
or he walked out of that conversation I
was like oh I changed my mind but still
getting the information is important and
so I think part of it is like if you're
an [ __ ] to everyone
people don't talk to you that's the
thing yeah right so it's like how do you
find the balance
and I think to your point like you can
ask tough questions in a nice way and
some people may not be able to realize
that that's actually a tough question
yeah because like oh they he did it with
a smile yeah or they're they're laughing
but like
if you had said uh hey Sam where'd you
get the money for buying seven percent
of Robin Hood like that's a pretty
direct question and either he answers it
or he doesn't uh and almost in some way
a non-answer is telling you a detail
yeah totally pay attention to I mean
what I am
I'm very I'm very proud that we did at
least as a firm we did ask these
questions we've been asking them for
years
um but you always want to be you always
want to be better
um so I just wish we asked them instead
of on a like
twice a year basis like an every week
basis yeah but like we were talking
earlier and so when all this news broke
somebody on Twitter of course was like
you guys are all [ __ ] morons like you
idiots yeah
that either interviewed these people or
um uh they were the us-based entity uh
at FTX uh worked with our media business
as an Advertiser as did a bunch of other
companies
um and they're like how did you not know
I was like well what question would you
have liked us to ask and this uh genius
smart ass said you should have asked if
they were taking FTX customer deposits
lending it to a their hedge fund who was
then posting it as collateral getting
leverage and then buying risky assets
okay
interesting combination of things you
want to put together there in that
question with hindsight uh
asked and then they just said no
what are you gonna do
right and so like to your guys Point
like you even if you ask the questions
if somebody just says no we don't do
that and it turns out they do do that
how what is the expectation like how
could you have known right and that's
what becomes kind of hard it's an
interesting question I mean and
I think it it forces us to it forces
people in a position like like your
position to
maybe scale back from certain folks I
mean I remember when we started the
block
um one thing that we we sort of decided
not to do because of how many people got
burnt by the icos was not do any
advertising with any sort of Ico company
um of course token projects have come
you know into the market that are far
more legitimate
um and and so you know are probably
would make folks more comfortable to to
take their ad ad dollars
and we're kind of we'll maybe we'll see
something similar with the centralized
crypto Brokers and Retail platforms
where maybe we won't it'll be it will
think twice or we'll think three times
or ask more questions not I mean I agree
with with your point that like yes you
can be lied to but maybe you know
folks in media will look for other
opportunities
um that are outside this more
retail-facing realm maybe
um you know athletic greens which is the
sponsor of my podcast
or other brands of that I'm an investor
athletic are you really perfect yeah
this is very incestuous go ahead I hope
they're not stealing I hope they're not
stealing uh customer funds and well the
only thing they're stealing is my 30
minutes of my morning where I enjoy a
delicious athletic greens and it gets me
ready for the day no one of the things
though I do think is uh it's something
we're actively thinking through I don't
know kind of how we're gonna deal with
it uh it is different though when you're
like hey there's a product that is
advertising like you give your money to
athletic greens or or ate sleep uh which
everyone loves to give you [ __ ] about
why why do you think why do they give
you such a hard time
like the market the market by two of my
best friends yeah right literally two of
my best friends uh I'm an investor in
the business I've helped them for a long
time all this stuff and uh some of it
was timing like all this stuff starts
happening whatever uh but also
uh we had made a video yeah for uh
social media or whatever ever and that's
just me hey I sleep when they sleep I've
talked about it I've Ad nauseam talked
about this for years right uh how much
I'm like I love this product and so we
made this video I posted it it did well
and they were like hey are you cool if
we put some ad dollars behind it
sure whatever right like I didn't think
twice about it next thing I know they're
very good at Performance Marketing all
over Facebook Instagram like all this
[ __ ] and it's me
like basically like almost like a
spokesperson and people are like
the bear Market is so bad yeah Palm
Shilling mattresses
and like look I'm a human I love the
internet I'm like that's check the
market is bad yeah you guys you got me
like that was a good one that was that
was a good one and so uh like in some
ways like
the feedback like I listened right I see
it uh it makes you laugh but also it's
like that's different if somebody goes
and they buy a mattress and like I don't
like the mattress
that's different than somebody puts
their assets into a platform and you can
say all you want like I went back and I
looked I've like tweets where people are
like tweeting me I'm like hey I don't
speak for the company but like here's
the frequently asked questions do your
own research on to write the risk
whatever but like still it's a product
that like their money is sitting there
versus buying a product and I think that
there's differences to that right and so
like we're trying to think through like
Hey how do you how do you navigate this
especially in a world that's like it's
built on finance
there's no clear answer it's it's just
it's difficult and I think like our job
is
it's it's required that we like
think very hard especially about the way
we you know
um advertise things write about things
talk about things
um especially as it pertains to
financial services products right we've
we go through our scripts we're very
diligent and think
um very hard about the language that we
use you know we we we appreciate our
sponsors of course but we try to
um stray from superlatives that might be
a bit um
overstated
but yeah it's not it's it's it's it's
it's it's not as simple as you know some
of your trolls might think which I think
is the bottom line
um mean Lords I like the meme Lords yes
but it's it's it's interesting
um you've kind of gone through your own
um
transition in a way this is Frank trying
to change the interview
first off you um so we're here in your
lovely offices this is the
this is the family office plus the
um the other the other firm that you're
sort of running yes what's the pop
Empire look like today
that's it that's it yeah that's it run
the business and invest nice it's um
I just try to do the things I enjoy
doing like I think that's another thing
right like if you look at obviously the
block by situation uh I wasn't an
investor in FTX but I'm investor I don't
know I've probably invested across every
fund that I've managed uh and my own
Capital maybe 200 companies right or 150
200 whatever it's some big number and
when you look at it I think one of the
things that people forget is that like
that's the business of investing is
taking risk and you risk capital and if
you are wrong for whatever reason
whether it's that company's fault
somebody else's fault whatever you lose
money like that is the feedback cycle uh
if you're right usually you make a lot
of money and Venture Capital tends to be
an industry where it is not about being
right more times than wrong it's
actually about being really really
really really really really right a few
times and actually being wrong most of
the time what do you do when a bet is
turning against you I I know one
investor now so that's interesting
because there was one investor I know
who flew to the Bahamas to get some
answers from Sam so in that situation
right uh I'm assuming I don't know I
think he said on National Television
yeah okay yeah he said on National
Television okay um and so like in that
situation I think it's because uh
there is
um
where there was Smoke there was the
thought there might be fire I think
right uh but like in other situations
where a company uh is even struggling
like you get on the phone you talk to
the town you try to be helpful but like
you're not running the company
right and every investor will tell you I
have Founders I've talked to
they're like I don't know what to do
tell me what to do and like I'll do it
and you give them the best information
you can or you introduce them to
somebody who's been through that
situation before sometimes they follow
it to a T and it doesn't work sometimes
they fall to a T and it works most of
the time though they're like thank you
for your opinion yeah I'll call you if I
need you yeah and they go and do
whatever they want right and so like but
like that's ultimately what you're
betting on it's like you're betting on
the people
especially if you're an early stage
investor to run the company and so I
think that like
one of the promises of this whole
industry is like capitalism and free
markets and all that kind of stuff and I
think the FTX situation is interesting
because really it was the crypto Market
that essentially self-regulated no it
was turbulent didn't feel good but like
somebody leaked a balance sheet to a
crypto reporter or a reporter at a
crypto Media company which then provided
the market information and then Market
participants decided to take actions
based on that information that
ultimately led to the downfall of the
second largest crypto Exchange
it's not like somebody showed up from uh
auditing firm it was like oh look at
this thing yeah right so I think like
that same ethos plays out when things go
right or or they don't but like
the people who are investing the capital
in the businesses you don't hear them
complaining you don't hear them
um
like being upset because I think they
know what they're kind of signed up for
right it's the things to an extent
though they played a role in sort of
creating a a capital markets uh for
crypto that were highly incentivized to
take on
a lot of risk right when when the
money's flowing in you know John Mack
said this that uh he was the CEO of
um
was it was it Merrill lyncher one of the
big bangs and he said well the music's
playing you've got to dance and all
these letters there was kind of a race
to the bottom as it were in terms of
thinking through collateral
um and rates and just being hyper
aggressive that was fueled in part by
the ample amounts of venture funds that
could sort of
feed into that frenzy yeah I don't know
how much uh Venture dollars like there's
a lot invested but if you look at these
companies like how much total did take
FTS as an example how much total do they
raise a billion
billions Bill two billion yeah right so
like let's say they raise 2 billion
that's on the higher end for sure but
like there are other companies that
raised a billion or two billion dollars
in technology in general right uh if you
look at other companies it's less
hundreds of millions but still that's a
[ __ ] ton of money right
um and so when you look at it like
overall I actually don't think that much
money really went into the top companies
compared to what people think it is like
it was happening so fast and to your
point like prices were going up so
quickly but if you actually take a step
back and you look
was it more or less than 10 billion
dollars hmm I don't know right we have
to do the math but let's say it was less
than 10 billion that is a really really
big number but the overall market cap
was hitting 3 trillion
so if 10 billion of venture went in
and you got three trillion
from an industry
and you have to make sure the numbers
are correct but like that's like a very
small amount of capital to create three
trillion dollars of value
now that doesn't it's not as clear-cut
because you have to look and say like
okay I want to just say though it's not
just the money I think your point is
right but also the expectation right of
the venture capitalist for when you
raise that next round right you want to
show hockey sticks oh that's Venture
Capital across the world and to show
that you need to you need to sort of
undercut your competitors and it was
quite the competitive market quite a
crowded Market yeah if you look at LCS
nexo block five Genesis so you can look
at like crypto but I would just say zoom
out from just the crypto industry it's
like the same things that drove Uber and
Lyft to fight with each other and like
spend a [ __ ] ton of money uh all of the
driver incentives the writer incentives
the rebates like all that stuff it's the
same I think it's 100 and so like to
your point uh venture capital is a home
run business it is a asymmetry business
and like asymmetry doesn't occur because
you grow 10 year over year right and so
regardless of the industry like that is
the the business of venture capital and
like most things there's a lot of good
that's come out of it saying like a VC
backed
Venture Capital back financial markets
is can be dangerous
as we've seen yeah um but also the
collateral thing I think is the big is
the big other Boogeyman here which is
you know in hindsight
Alameda nft or Alameda were they were
borrowing money with collateral tied to
the firm themselves so you have this
wrong way collateral that effectively
doubles down the risk of their
counterparty right because if the
collateral is let's say the collateral
was Gatorade if FTX goes down doesn't
impact Gatorade the collateral is still
good but if FTX goes down in your
collateral serum ftt Solana to an extent
that's that's a different game that's
bad yeah but I I do think
um there's a lot of people I mean I was
a pretty big
um critic of the Ico Mania it sounds
like you guys were as well uh back in
2017 2018.
um I literally got booed off a stage I
don't know if I ever touched this uh
there was a a battleship I should have
known already the conference was on a
battleship
um and uh I was invited to speak I went
it was a fireside chat me and the uh the
uh was it with Ian bellina no uh it was
the guy who ran the conference and he
was asking me questions and I was honest
I said hey I don't think you know I
think that if you're doing this stuff
like it's probably going to be on
registered Securities or whatever and
they were like bullying me and then as I
was leaving the conference the next guy
on the stage was like don't listen to
that guy's an idiot I was like wow okay
so like haters I've been dealing with
this for a long time like welcome to the
party
um but I do think your point about like
there will be changes happening in the
industry my last question for you is
just like what do you think the changes
will be well I think we're gonna rethink
what what collateral is and and the sort
of parameters around how they centralize
crypto Brokers lenders operate we've
tried several times in the past and we
is carrying a lot of weight I've not
been involved in sort of the self
regulatory rank is actually the
pseudonymous person yeah exactly I'm the
hand that that sort of well we could
talk about the fact that I feel like a
lot of the times I put out a story about
a trend and then whatever that trend is
tanks and I think there's a whale who's
counter trading my monitoring my art my
articles my news
be that anyway moving on from that I
said he was Sam could have been could
have been um would you be mad if you
found that out no I mean it is it is
what it is but it's happened quite a bit
like I've written like pieces where I'm
like just looking at the data volatility
is at an all-time high
and the next day it just completely like
falls off cliff it happens all the time
you should write an article about how
bitcoin's price is going down yeah right
so uh I think that these agencies tried
to come to the fold and they really
didn't have that much success in kind of
creating parameters around how these
firms should engage with each other
there's been attempts by various folks
but none of them have really taken off I
think we need to get serious about that
and I think that if we don't The
Regulators certainly will will force our
hand in doing that
um
I think that's the big thing like just
like this was a this was a problem of of
the way our Capital markets and crypto
functioned
with a lack of controls a lack of risk
management a lack of counterparty risk
management
and I think that's what changes and if
it doesn't
then
it's it's going to be difficult for just
the sort of you know Capital formation
to happen in this market I think that
you'll see
D5 rails step in right I think D5
lending protocols will sort of have
their moment right where
um people might think about the the sort
of the element of transparency being
beneficial relative to what was going on
at some of these deaths
and
um I'm hopeful for that I'm hopeful for
those two things sort of
um establishing themselves and and
creating a stronger Foundation
um from which we can
exit out of this this crisis
um but I'm more hopeful than I was three
weeks ago I mean it was kind of like the
fog of War had still
you know still hanging over our head
now I think you know especially with you
know knock wood Bitcoin sort of keeping
its price level as it is that's that's a
good sign um it's not it's not you know
it doesn't feel quite it doesn't it
feels more like dramatic and like almost
entertaining and and bizarre
emphasis on bizarre then 2017 or 2018
but it doesn't sound as um doesn't feel
rather as hopeless I mean 2019 was
pretty pretty grim
but we're still here still here all
right where can we send people to find
you on the internet just you can get me
at at the uh at fintech Frank
I don't know why this is funny it's just
so what's my Twitter handle
um and then the block dot Co we changed
our URL since the last time I was on the
block.co who's got the com.com so you
know what's funny I think the block.com
is like an Australian home improvement
show
you have a mustache that could be the
contractor
and then there's another one like the
block.io is like a
I'm pretty sure like a Peruvian
restaurant in Arlington Virginia
so shout out to them yeah they probably
get some traffic for you guys awesome
all right we'll do it again in the
future thank you thanks